في النصف الاول من رمضان رصد الجمهور
والنقاد بعض الاخطاء سواء كانت تخص
التاريخ او الملابس والديكور في الدراما
وعرضتها للسخريه والاستغراب ونستعرض بعضها
مسلسل سر الباتع تصدر الاهتمام حيث كانت
للجمهور تعليقات حول مشاهد الحمله
الفرنسيه على مصر اهمها انتعال احد
المماليك حذاء لمركه عالميه لم تكن موجوده
بالطبع وقتها مظاهر الجنود الفرنسيين ايضا
لفتت انتباهه المشاهدين حيث لم يبدوا
فرنسيين ابدا بعضهم اسمر البشره ويتحدث
بالعاميه المصريه مسلسل رساله الامام التي
يتناول سيره الامام الشافعي لم يسلم من
حده الانتقادات في التاريخ او اللغه او
الحوار نفسه وصولا لاستخدام ابيات شعريه
لشاعر سوري باعتبارها للامام الشافعي في
المسلسل السوري الزند ظهرت الواح للطاقه
الشمسيه في احد مشاهده في حين قصه المسلسل
تعود للعهد العثماني هذا بخلاف انتقادات
للهجه الساحليه الجبليه المستخدمه في
الاحداث اخيرا مسلسل ستهم للفنانه روجينا
التي تقوم بدور امراه صعيديه ترتدي ملابس
الرجال لكنها ظهرت باسنان ناصعه البياض لا
تتناسب ابدا مع الشخصيه
على كل حال نبقى مع الدراما الجدل كبير
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بعد ان طال
مقص الرقيب مسلسل الجبل الاحمر التونسي
وحذف بعض المشاهد بحجه انها لا تتماشى مع
طبيعه شهر رمضان المزيد في تقرير كواليس
مع سهى الوعل واعداد ايهم القاسم
اعطي
المزيد لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات